Okay,
we should be live here. Hello.
Let me set the uh the Twitch title real
quick
All right,
we should be good.
Hey, Tim. So, starter stream
announcements. Where the hell have I
been for a week? Comcast.
Comcast. Comcast. Comcast. Go [ __ ]
yourself. Um,
awful, awful, awful company. They
basically will just dick you around
while stalling because their service is
broken for a week straight.
Um, Starlink gets here at the end of the
week. So hopefully internet is stable
until then.
Um, yeah, it's really annoying. They
have the goal to like tell you, "Oh
yeah, it's totally on your end." And
then they go, "Actually, it's kind of on
our end." But now it's on your end. Oh,
actually, wait, it's still on our end.
Nope, now it's on your end. Now it's on
our end. It's
just not a not a fun time. Uh terrible
company. Anyways,
I have been kind of doing little bits of
stuff what I can off of my hotspot in
the meanwhile, plus handling a couple
client things.
Um
let me go over the current state of
research.
SL took long to get there.
Wait, what?
Oh, darling. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How do I get into RL research? I've been
doing this since uh sophomore undergrad,
and I was doing like random ML before
that.
How you can get into RL research though
is my guides on X. I have lots of good
educational materials for a variety of
skill backgrounds.
Okay,
I'm still sort of waking up here, which
is odd because I've already been for a
run and everything, but for whatever
reason, today's a little slow. It's
actually the reason I wanted to boot up
the stream um
to sort of have to talk through things.
So where we are at the moment, we have a
version on Soabot with a lot of domain
hacks that essentially just by putting
the right data into the state buffer,
you can solve 15 levels in a row back to
back, which is all the levels I put
together for this benchmark.
Uh in 1.4 4 billion steps with a 50k
parameter model which takes about 4
minutes
without the domain specific stuff. It
doesn't work. So we are essentially now
we have a version that's decent but
doesn't solve. It gets like maybe 13
score and then we have the Oracle
version that has 15 score and we're
going to try to push from both
directions in order to get back to where
we have. Yeah, I'll explain. Let me
actually explain. It's it's right here.
This is what the oracle is at the
moment. So,
the guide, yeah, the guide is um I'll
post it real quick. Going to be a
slightly slow start to the morning.
Yeah. So, for anyone new around here,
all of my educational materials, there's
some on the website, but then most of
them are just here on X. So, some of
these are cutting edge research
articles. Like this is somewhat
accessible, but this is the
state-of-the-art in the field. Um, and
then we have more just pure education
stuff like right here and right here.
This is great if you're a newer
programmer or if uh the way that we does
do things around here seems alien to
you. This is how you do science and
research. All my best advice in one
place.
Okay. So, let me talk about the current
algorithm. So we take the current uh the
standard PO baseline. We set about 25%
of the ends to use as curriculum ends.
And uh the curriculum m for the oracle
record every single state that is seen
in every env.
And as soon as an environment solves uh
the next level. So as soon as you get
one lucky solve, you take the last 256
steps. So going backwards through the
buffer pretty much you get 2566
steps worth of state data from that
solve. So you essentially get the full
level solve
and curriculum learning just samples
from this segment and resumes from
everything along that solve.
Uh if you get a new solve that is faster
like a better solve of the same level
that will be used to replace the state
buffer. If you get a new solve for the
next level, that will be saved, but
won't replace the state buffer until you
are confidently solving the current
level
and I think this is a smaller deal.
So essentially though this is only 256
states. So by keeping a very small
buffer of curriculum states, you can
solve the problem.
if you know how to put the right data
in. So now the question is can we get
something that is this good without
heristics?
That sounds much more like uh unlike go
explore this is not limited to
deterministic environments.
I actually did start with something even
more like go explore though Tim. I used
random exploration as the policy.
But we were able to remove that and just
use the policy itself and it does even
better than uh than that which is good.
Oh, I put the Yeah. So Arch um stuff
gets filtered automatically.
Seal reward and terminal buffers
after setting the state
So, this is Soaban Arch. Um, this is
Tim's environment.
It's I don't know if you've never seen
this game.
Why are these so fancy looking? Oh, here
you go.
So, it's something like this, though.
This has way too many boxes. People
write really weird levels with this. Um,
so you want to put all the Why is this
so damn complicated, man? Where's just
like this the standard so
yeah this is like you want to put the
boxes
onto the targets
and it's very difficult. I actually have
no idea how the [ __ ] to do this one.
It's very easy to screw it up.
Oh, 367. So, this is ludicrously hard.
Cool.
That's not me just being an idiot. This
is like a a more simpler level, it looks
like. Right.
Uh, this one has to go here.
The trick to this one is that this one
Oh, I'm [ __ ] Hang on.
These are like surprisingly tricky. Even
the easy ones
there. Okay. So that's like So that's So
uh we have
how many levels in a row? 15. 15 levels
in a row that you have to beat.
Struggling to find main focus for PhD
needs to be around explainable RL.
So I don't think you're going to get
just like
oh we're going to specifically do
hyperprim. I think explainable
explainable RL is on its own a narrow
enough topic for a PhD thesis and then
what you would do is you essentially go
to different areas as uh you make
progress and as things become clearer.
So yeah like understanding the various
interactions of hyperparameters is a
very uh reasonable thing to do. In fact
that's something that we need in puffer
very heavily. Um
there's some sort of visualization stuff
you can do on policy behaviors though I
think that's harder. I think the
explanability around the algorithms
themselves is much more likely to yield
fruit there.
I also wouldn't sweat too much, Tim.
Like the important thing is that in at
least in my
You end up with common a common thread
around your work just naturally from
doing that.
Let me just put the plug this back in.
Stupid camera thing, man.
Nowhere to get started to make a
population sim environment. Motivations
to work on prediction markets.
Uh, we do some finance type work and
financial simulation professionally.
Uh, our general guides. Let me fix my
stupid camera. Hang on.
There we are. Um,
yeah, it's just my just the general like
just the general environment guides are
where you get started, frankly.
just cut out for a bit. The camera or
the mic? Is the mic cutting out or just
the camera?
If the camera's cutting out, that's
fine. I can deal with that.
Okay. So, let me actually go through
this.
Internet is okay for now. actually
um it's been down all like for a week.
Starlink is here this weekend and I'll
be switching over to that. Mic cuts out.
Ah, damn. Okay, I guess the um the
camera drop somehow kills that as well.
That's really obnoxious.
I will see if I can do anything about
that, but we'll try this for now.
Okay. Yeah. So Tim, it's just like I
wouldn't sweat too much
having the exact thing that you want to
do for PhD. It's more you need something
an area or something. So I wanted to
make a big fancy sim in order to do a
bunch of research on that that you
couldn't do with other sims. That was
neural MMO, right? And we had the
inspiration from MMOs, but I didn't know
exactly every algorithmic thing or every
like question I wanted to ask. and my
PhD was considered to have a tremendous
amount of foresight and clarity. Like
practically nobody comes in with the
level of specificity that I did. That
should give you some uh some context. So
just wanting to make RL more explainable
and having some ideas for areas where uh
you can like some ideas for areas where
with high confidence you can improve
like that is sufficient.
It depends what you mean by that.
Um,
like do you mean
you can just make it deterministic by
seeding the softmax? Right. I don't know
if there's something else to it.
I'm two years in.
That sounds like most students. Tim,
you basically I think you should just
pick like a high confidence project that
you're very interested in where you
think that it's going to be, you know,
make a big difference.
Um, you spend some time on that and that
will guide the rest of your work.
Hello. Welcome folks.
Hopefully the internet will be stable
today.
I will say that Tim just generally if
you like the type of work that you see
here which I assume you do um investing
in low-level development skills along
the way wherever you can is tremendously
beneficial.
But, you know, there's also plenty of
room for science side stuff on um
hyperparam sweeps and the algorithm and
the like. Actually, that's probably the
biggest spot at the moment where we need
things is that hyperparam algorithm,
the previous method. No, Tim, this is an
iteration upon it. So, this is I guess I
should provide some context. So, what
I've been doing for the last couple days
off stream is um I've been essentially
adding a bunch of domain knowledge to
that thing until I get it to solve all
15 levels staveably
with a very small model and fast. And
now I'm trying to strip away bits of
that in order to tease out what are the
actual things required to make state
sets useful.
records every state in per trajectory at
interval one. So this interval is
configurable. This is not domain
assumption. Detects a solve using
terminal plus reward and sequence pause.
This is domain specific because we're
treating rewards as solves. Only admits
solve histories that start from puzzle
entry. This is domain specific. We're
saying that we only want to record
states of the current level. Replaces
the state buffer with the full retained
solve segment.
Um that is
I think we have this in the main
algorithm as well. This is fine.
Samples uniformly from that segment.
That could be fine.
Holds future better pending segment but
only promotes after the current saved
level reaches 80% latch gate. So it's
mostly around okay sampling differences
and then the ordering I suppose.
his test set.
So, Tim, what I did is I sorted I sorted
the puzzles by the amount of time that
they take to solve with random actions,
and I'm just using the first 15 of them.
So
the first map is very easy. It takes
So the first map is very easy. It takes 15,000 steps on average to solve it
15,000 steps on average to solve it
randomly. But by the end, you know, the
last map here takes 38 million steps for
one lucky solve with a random policy.
You know, if you sum all these up, like
80 uh 100
probably like 150ish million steps worth
of exploration, 130 million steps worth
of exploration on average
across maps.
That number
Proper science are small build. Yeah,
hundreds of billions to solve, right?
But arch like the key is those are not
solvable by random exploration. You
won't have an algorithm that doesn't
include some additional form of state
coverage which is outside the scope of
this update um that ever solves those
unless you're getting general solve
information from the rest of the levels
or you're using intermediate rewards. I
should mention I'm doing this fully
sparse with no intermediate rewards.
So, this is very much more science side
work, which is something that we don't
see as often on uh on the channel, but
this is like essentially I took the base
algorithm, I added information bit by
bit until I forced it to be able to
solve this whole thing efficiently and
consistently. And now I'm stripping out
bits to see, you know, what what can I
actually do without
This solves 15 levels fully sparse, Tim.
So essentially if you can get what I've
shown by this very hacky Oracle method
is if you get the right data into your
state set buffer you can solve the
problem incredibly efficiently with a
tiny model and with like one lucky
success per
like we're not [ __ ] around here right
the goal is not for state such to be a
little better. This should be the god
algorithm.
I've had several people tell me they
could not get this working, but I think
that this like I would be, let's put it
this way, I would be shocked if this is
not just the god algorithm.
Yes. So, Jess, I've shown essentially
that if you get the right data into the
buffer, it works. And now we're figuring
out if there's a generalizable way to
get the right data into the buffer.
Oh, hey Aether. Um, we have uh we have
overcooked in puffer. I have not
experimented with it anywhere near
enough, but it's there and I actually
would really like to have somebody to do
the experiments on that. It's super
fast. It has like a few different
scenarios in it already.
It's way less code than the original
Crazy Overcooked codebase.
Well, the expectation, Jess, is I'm kind
of going to use Soaban as the dev
environment and then we're going to test
it on other ends.
bit like this is substantially stronger
than imitation Tim. So it's a harder to
learn signal than imitation. But because
you're doing state sets, this is pure on
policy RL. You can explore all
surrounding states and it works with
stochastic environments as well. Unlike
imitation, this is like this is a
ludicrously ludicrously powerful
algorithm if we can find a reasonably
good way to get data into the buffer.
Low-level resources.
I mean, the way that I started doing C
is very, very stupid. Um, we were kind
of doing some Sythony things with Puffer
because I didn't know what I was doing.
I ran a 50K and like I guess I somehow
scrambled my brain cuz I couldn't think
straight for 3 days and then I just
started writing C.
I was just like, "Oh yeah, cool. We're
doing everything in C now." And that
turned out to be a good thing.
Um, but I kind of just went like, ah,
it's just, you know, it's it's a basic
language. There's not much to learn.
Look, you have data. It's stat it's in
static memory. You have pointers instead
of having variables that hide the
pointers from you. Big deal.
So, I really just sort of started doing
it with very very limited knowledge,
just like whatever I remembered from my
systems course a decade ago. And
I suppose just based on my knowledge of
programming already, it was a very
natural transition.
We implemented in jacks. Ours will be
much faster and much simpler than the
jacks one. Guarantee you.
I've got a whole deck on don't use
jacks.
If you really need an N to be on GPU,
you can write cudacy. But most of the
time, you don't even have to do that.
You can write normal C and it's easy.
What the hell is this?
Now, the fair people were chilled. Like,
I'm not telling them that they're stupid
for using Jack's Tim. Like, on the
contrary, they're very smart, which is
why they're able to make Jacks work at
all. It's just that they can't. Like I'm
saying like look, you can get your stuff
to work, but you can't get your stuff to
work and still have free time. If you do
it with puffer, you can get yourself
your stuff to work and have free time.
How to vectorize. I do a bit of rust
now. No, no, no, man. C is so much
simpler than Rust. So, so, so much
simpler than Rust.
And I hate Rust as a language.
If you want to talk about a ridiculously
bloated and complicated like that
nothing about Rust appeals to me
like C is a very very simple language
having to vectorize [ __ ]
So you don't have to vectorize anything
in your code. You use our
multi-threading across ends. You
literally just write like brain deadad
first year of systems programming level
C and it's faster than the damn jacks
and simpler.
And I have to not just be like ignoring
[ __ ] here. I have to actually pay
attention. Uh
even though I'm I'm basically treating
this entire code branch as throwaway.
Like this is just to develop the method.
I still have to make sure it's not doing
dumb things. Like it kept like some dumb
thing over here
plus Shaw.
What?
Those words don't go together in any way
I can see that makes sense.
I'm not sure what you're on with there.
Yeah, Puffer is very simple, but it also
doesn't get in your way. Puffer doesn't
make things simple by hiding complexity
from you. It's just simple all the way
through.
Everyone else is stupid like in the
Middle Ages. That's what I say, man.
It's like I really don't think I'm that
smart. It's just I look around and
everybody is like eating crayons and
huffing paint.
And the problem is that like really
really shitty bloated advice is now
baked into all the language models. So
when people like go to like check things
from their favorite model, it also tells
them stupid [ __ ]
Okay. So this is a
so this is a small removal of domain
knowledge from the oracle
and
we will see whether the oracle still
solves. It still has some domain
knowledge.
If this does not still solve or is much
worse.
like just know how a pointer works as
well. Literally that. Yeah.
See, this is why I say this is all
throwaway, cuz what the [ __ ] is this
thing doing? If this doesn't work, uh,
if this does work, I will continue
stripping things. If this does work, I I
mean, here, if this does work, I'll
continue stripping things. If this
doesn't work, I'll have to figure out
what the hell this is.
broad advantage from the checkpoint grid
existing pending mastery gate. Okay, so
this is just because we're w we're
wiring the generic thing to something
with heavy domain knowledge. So fine,
that's plumbing. Cool.
What's the plan today? So
uh we are very very stupidly taking this
oracle method that I have made to solve
a very very hard benchmark and we're
stripping off little bits of domain
knowledge one at a time uh one bit at a
time to see if we can get a general
version of this algorithm. If we could
get this oracle level performance
generally we win like we have the god
algorithm at that point.
And these experiments aren't super long.
They're like six minutes max.
This flicker is very annoying. But can I
just like
I'm just going to make the text on this
terminal super small so it doesn't
flicker for stream.
What's the benchmark? So, the benchmark
is uh a collection of 15 levels of
Silkabon in increasing difficulty. You
only get a reward of one when you solve
a level. Um, and if you fail a level,
you have to go all the way back to the
beginning. You have to solve 15 levels
in a row.
Is encoding a bunch of domain knowledge
an actually viable strategy?
Well, Aaron, um, so here I have,
let me hang on. I haven't streamed in a
few days, so my
can barely speak in full like proper
sentences. Let me actually formulate my
thoughts and let me give you the full
explanation behind this thing.
Okay, the prior here is that state sets
should be a ludicrously
ludicrously powerful addition to the
learning algorithm. They literally let
you jump to the point in this uh in the
problem where you're currently having
difficulty and focus all of your
learning efforts right there. So it
literally just lets you teleport to any
area in the problem that you're having
trouble or like where you're currently
getting signal without having to go
through the whole rest of the
environment to get there. So for very
long running environments for instance
with environments with incredible
sparity this should be a ridiculously
powerful technique.
Um very very strong prior here right
that this type of method should work.
Um, second point, this has almost never
been tried because
a lot of more theoretical people did not
think that it made sense to assume that
you can set the state of your
environment. The key insight from Puffer
is we build all our own environments
anyways. We're really good at it. We do
it professionally in a variety of
domains. Probably anything that we do
with Puffer in the future is going to
involve us building some pretty crazy
custom Sims. And it's really easy to
make a sim state setable.
So very very high confidence that this
method should work. Very low amount of
prior lit out there on methods like this
equals we should be able to just crush
everything with state sets. Now because
there's not that much prior lit, it's a
pretty big space of possible algorithms
to explore. And my first attempts seemed
really good, but then when we really
optimized our baseline, the baseline
ended up doing just as well because
Puffer 4 is just a ridiculously good
baseline. So the standard goes up,
right?
As a result, I came up with a few
benchmarks. I found one that now seems
genuinely very hard to do without any
sort of curriculum. I ran a sweep on it.
We can't solve it without curriculum.
I'm going to see if we can get a version
of this to solve with curriculum on a
small model by any means necessary which
I've done and start stripping stuff
away. That's the approach.
How long is many steps?
Uh this these experiments are running
two billion steps but it's using a tiny
50k parameter model.
pretty much badge. It lets you do that.
Imagine having to play a symphony,
right? But in order to practice the
symphony, you literally have to play 30
minutes to go to the five notes that you
keep messing up.
Why don't academic people look into
state sets?
academic people, first of all, they
don't write their own environments.
Um, so like they're stuck with a big set
of baselines that don't have this
feature. They don't understand that it's
really easy to make Sims state setable
when you're writing them yourself
either. And they kind of just take the
environment as a fixed thing. They're
not including the building of the
environment as part of the solution.
It's just myopia because it's just not
enough engineering in academia.
Actually,
that's not like a Soulslike experience,
right? Because you have bonfires.
It would be like doing Dark Souls
without bonfires.
Okay, so this is dramatically
dramatically worse.
um, this specific problem, the optimal
trajectories are not very long at all.
So, right here, this is 250 steps or
whatever. I think the full solve is only
like 350 steps. However, the exploration
to find this uh very short trajectory,
it is like here. The last level alone
would take 38 million steps of random
trials just to get one lucky solve with.
So, it's a very hard exploration
problem. It scales up from only 15k
random steps up to 38 million steps by
level 15.
The algorithms aren't that good yet.
Uh, our algorithms are quite good.
So, Puffer does make the existing stuff
run very fast, but we also do our own
research.
Like this is not just a pure engineering
project. We have the best hyperparameter
sweep algorithm out there. We have the
best on policy learning out there. We
have the state-of-the-art hardware
efficient architecture for reinforcement
learning. Um we have state-of-the-art
for environment simulation for general
like fast simulation.
We have lots and lots of advancements.
Ideal case is that it can be trained
without curriculum? No. Um, so it's
basically it's essentially impossible
that any algorithm could train
efficiently without curriculum.
The only other way that this would work
efficiently is if off policy RL worked.
And off policy RL doesn't work. We found
this last summer.
And it like very clearly will not work.
Yeah. Yeah. So I [ __ ] it up. Cool. I
thought so.
We do need to iterate on protein a
little bit more.
starting a IIRL PhD student.
Uh I guess my my articles mostly
how to view science um
ML and like research that article was it
programming and ML article and then the
RL article in particular
those are generally my two just best
educational pieces.
It does take more than 100 or 200 a lot
of the time though.
Now, our sweep stuff is fairly
efficient. So the reason Tim that um
you're needing it to be so long is
because it's very slowly expanding the
compute frontier on your specific
problem. So I wouldn't be surprised that
it's mostly just keeping the same
hyperparameters and running for longer
um in your case. Like we could probably
just try something like that or we could
try to like fit you probably could just
fit a line to the Pareto Frontier.
I wouldn't be surprised.
Okay, so this is where we have to be
careful because this has probably just
[ __ ] a whole bunch of things up.
Um, this is also one of the reasons I
wanted to stream today because like yes,
it's faster to do this with codecs than
it would be for me to do it myself, but
it's also incredibly irritating
Uh, wait, Tiny Puff One.
Tiny Puff One is not supposed to be
down.
I'm going to be very annoyed if it is.
Check tail scale
and ask Spencer if he's doing anything.
Expanding compute and testing loads of
stuff.
is it actually doing 10k runs though, or
is it just like taking forever on the
existing runs cuz they keep getting
longer.
Need some training first. Anyways, wait.
to know which state sets are
challenging. Wouldn't we need some
training first?
Yeah. So, um the mental model you should
have for SOAN here is that you'll very
quickly learn that value function should
always be zero cuz you never get any
reward, right? And then the first time
you get a reward, you'll get a big spike
in advantage. And that spike in
advantage should be enough for you to
fill the state buffer without knowing
anything about the domain specifics. The
first any sparse reward problem should
look like that.
I'm letting it do all this crap, but
we're going to check here.
Wouldn't hit the limit.
Wait, what do you mean the limit?
10k experiments.
H
I code a lot by hand. It depends what
I'm doing.
Like none of this stuff is going to get
kept in the uh the final version. So
basically what I'm doing now is this is
just rapid prototyping of research stuff
uh with the assumption that all the code
for this is going to be total crap and
I'm going to have to first pair this
thing down to a much more minimal
implementation with codeex and then I'm
going to have to go through it by hand
and I'm probably going to have to
rearchitect it multiple times because
this thing has integrated it completely
stupidly.
generic states
scoring
oracle admission is solve only
Okay, so it's it's still done something
ridiculous, but at least we'll be able
to see if this does anything.
Well, I'm not letting it figure stuff
out badge. I'm not just like saying,
hey, come up with ideas and implement
them. I'm guiding that process
completely, right? I'm saying, okay, you
know, implement this, implement that,
change the algorithm like this, change
the algorithm like that. So I have this
thing has basically added like none of
the core ideas on this algorithm
autonomously. Uh what it is contributing
is fast well not run fast like very
inefficient but it's contributing quick
like dirty versions of those
implementations in CUDA which as you can
see I've lost most of the speed of
puffer in the process of doing this but
like this is still three to four times
faster than it would be in pietorch. So
this implements very shitty version in
CUDA on the codebase. I run experiments.
Uh if this number gets 15 without using
domain knowledge, we win. And like once
I get the generic version of this
algorithm to work, assuming that I can,
then I will be manually or much more
directedly pairing down the code. And
then I'm going to make sure that the
final version of the code is clean and
fast and correctly designed and all of
that.
The ideas have to be very well described
though. The idea cannot just be like you
know implement an algorithm that uses
state set to improve performance right
like I wrote a precise like a precise
spec such that anybody that implemented
that spec would get pretty much the
exact same thing that was my starting
point and then each change from there
was a well-defined operation with very
little ambiguity
yes I am testing the new algorithm on
boxabon this is a version of boxabon
that I did on top of the original that
gives you a fixed set of 15 levels in a
fixed order and you have to solve all 15
levels one after the other in order to
win. You only get one reward per level.
So, it's very very sparse.
And this is a good test algorithm.
You can also see the [ __ ] tons of
metrics here. Like for instance, these
metrics, this is the number of millions
of steps that it has taken after it gets
its first reward on level one to achieve
an 80% solve rate on level one. And
like, you know, on level 10, it's 48
million steps from the first reward
until it fully solves. And I've been
testing all of these with various
different methods as well to make sure
that we're consistently latching on in a
reasonable amount of steps.
going through research, try to provide
meaningful contributions.
Thank you.
I stream most of my research. I was
supposed to be live the whole last week,
but then Comcast decided that uh that
wasn't going to happen. Uh I do have a
meeting today in a couple of hours, hour
and a half, and that'll be a long one.
Got some client work to do.
might be back after that depending.
We'll see.
And multi-agent planning hopefully using
puffer. Hope so. And yeah, congrats on
that.
Multi-agent planning. We have lots of
multi-agent M. We have lots of
multi-agent M. The one piece of advice
that I would definitely give you on that
is don't assume that you need like a
model based or explicit algorithm to do
planning. I would lean much more heavily
towards like probably current good
algorithms can do a lot of that stuff
implicitly and spend a lot of time
making sure that you know the real
failure cases before you go making new
algorithms.
I'm porting an MTU state set. Should I
do that myself
or can I have an LM do it? Uh, if you
have a well-built puffer N like on 40,
you can literally have an LLM do it. And
the reason I say that Arch is there's
only really one way to do it. like you
need to make sure it doesn't do anything
stupid, but it's basically just taking
almost all of the variables from your
end your env putting them into a new
state in contiguous memory
and then replacing all the uh the call
signatures on functions from like end
pointer to state pointer. That's it.
Yeah, that's exactly what you do. You
reference this thing. and you give it a
you give it the like the exact um spec
of how we do our states our state sets.
Um there are a couple places where it
does stupid things I noticed, but for
the most part it's fine.
Place the whole buffer with one solid
state.
I'm just trying to figure out what we
can ablate here.
The problem is it's very brittle because
it has one segment.
number one on Kaggle is using RL. Go for
it, man.
Be fun.
Well, we'll have a few decisions to make
here. I think we can probably quite
reasonably get a larger buffer version
of the Oracle to work.
Then we can ablate one of these other
things perhaps.
Yeah. So, this is a difference in what I
expected. Um,
it looks like we might end up having to
save trajectory segments instead of
saving individual states.
It is somewhat obnoxious that it's like
this.
But the thing is when you get high
advantage data, right?
Well,
this is more so a matter of the way that
we have um our roll out structured in
segments.
So,
if this does work, we're all good. If
this doesn't work,
it actually would be kind of weird if
this doesn't work.
We will see.
Essentially, this is just giving more
diverse um
state set data to work with. So, this
should be substantially more robust, I
would think.
Yeah, the gating.
Not get ahead of ourselves, but we're
going to try to ablate the gating next
if this works.
No level 10 solves. So, this stays at
negative one. You see right here, this
metric until we get a lucky solve. So,
right now, that was when we got the
first lucky solve of level 10. And then
we're going to count the number of
million steps it takes before the policy
learns from getting the first solve. So
right
here, it took 80 million steps from the
time that it got the very first solve
until it was consistently solving level
10 or 80% of the time,
which I think is actually very
reasonable because we're only allocating
like 25% of the ends um to use
curriculum. So,
I think this is perfectly fine.
We're on level 11 in 2 minutes.
And we're jumping straight to 12, it
looks like.
Yep, we're at level 12. That's good.
Need 15, though. You really need to have
the full benchmark solved for it to be
convincing.
The current domain knowledge um it's
using knowledge of the level structure.
So it's basically keeping data in the
buffer for the current level until
you're consistently solving it. So if
you get lucky solves of the next level,
it's not sticking that in yet. And um
there are a few other things to it as
well.
that make it like substantially domain
engineered.
Now the thing is we don't actually
understand at all to what degree we need
these things, right? We just have them
at the moment.
Uh it got stuck a long time on level 13
there.
It did get just stuck for a long time.
Oh, hang on. No, we're on 14. This is
not bad.
It is possible to get unlucky on a level
for a little while.
15.
Come on. Get level 15.
It hasn't even gotten a single lucky
solve on 15 yet.
So, right now, it's not expected to
start learning
really. No solves.
Isn't this supposed to just be like 38
mil in?
I guess we do have to wait all the way.
Yeah. Okay. It's supposed to be like 100
or 200 mil.
Okay, that's fine.
Still no solves. What the hell?
Looked fine. It just got stuck on this
for too long.
entropy is high.
I don't know how we wouldn't be getting
a solve.
I mean, it is possible. It's entirely
possible to just get unlucky here
cuz it's like 38 million
Four.
See? Yeah, you can just get unlucky.
Not this unlucky though.
Yeah. Oh, it got it right at the end.
Yeah.
It's not going to have time to learn
this.
weakest blocks by
advantage.
It should be latching on.
This is actually where we're going to be
able to use advantage.
Yeah, Jess. So, that's what I'm
approximating in my head is like we got
unlucky, but we really shouldn't have
gotten that unlucky. So, there's
something a little wrong.
Yeah. No, I'm I'm doing decently well
here, Jess.
As you can see, this type of work is
just really slow and obnoxious cuz it's
very experiment bound. And I managed to
get it down to a six-minute experiment
for testing. But I couldn't get it any
lower than this because 40 is just so
ludicrously good that a lot of quite
sparse problems that you can solve
faster than this like 40 will just
figure it out.
We picked the 15 levels.
Yeah. So, Tim, I literally just I took
the first thousand maps of Soabon and I
ran one billion steps of random
exploration on each of them.
Tim, I swept the hell out of it. So, if
it solves it, I have no idea.
And um even the ones that did decently
well, I think we got to 11 at some
point. It was with a really long run
with a giant model.
This is basically the most confident I
can be reasonably about a benchmark with
this.
Every single person said their paper was
reviewed by an LLM.
Well, stop submitting to [ __ ]
conferences, man.
Literally delete peer review at this
point. It's doing nothing but wasting
everybody's bloody time.
Unless you're going to say like LLM
review equals banned from univers like
banned from conference and your
organization is banned from conference
as well until they fire or expel you.
That would work.
How would you run the process
for review?
If you wanted to do a review, it's very
very simple like
um your qualification has to be more
than ever submit like ever got a paper
accepted anywhere.
And
there would probably have to be some
sort of semi like some sort of automated
review just to get rid of LLM written
papers.
But aside from those, like the policy
would be if you use an LLM, well, the
policy would be if you submit an LLM
written paper or if you submit an LLM
written review, you're banned from the
conference and your company or your
university is also banned from the
conference until they expel or fire you.
How's the runescape end coming? Val is
doing great on that
and so is Jon with his fight caves end.
Okay, this is good so far. We'll see. Um
we'll see if this helps at all or not.
Yeah, the gates are closing wrong now
somehow. Stupid thing. We'll see if this
does any better. If not, we'll just go
back. They took issue with by puffer
white paper. Yeah, which one best paper
reward basically same manuscript at RLC
the next year.
factorial type en
uh you could implement one but no we
don't have one of those action spaces
would be a little tricky
general are hot mess the thing is like
there are people who are genuinely
trying in that space it's just Like the
administration incentives combined with
the conference system and the review
system, like basically everything
conspires to prevent you from actually
being able to focus on the [ __ ] you care
about.
And the funding system, don't even get
me started on that crap.
how would I resolve that? Well, with my
paper, the guy didn't submit a real
review. He pasted it into an LLM and
biased the uh the senior review. So that
would just be like a insta ban from
conference and also sanction the guy's
organization.
Like people do this [ __ ] because there
are no penalties and they get away with
ICML, I think, was it ICML? One of the
conferences actually did something good,
which was um people that submitted
shitty LLM reviews had their own papers
rejected. That was good.
Where you get paid regardless of being
uh well, academia is actually where you
get paid nothing regardless of if you're
mediocre or not. So yeah, very
socialist.
You get paid nothing regardless of
anything.
It's actually worse if you're better
because if you're better, then you're
explicitly choosing to make like 20
times less than you could make easily
elsewhere.
I don't know. Ang Golf. Um I think that
there's a very decent chance that in 20
years we treat the uh the AI CEOs today
worse than we treat like the um like the
cigarette execs.
Yeah, but engulf that's like that's on
them for being lazy, right?
Like that's the student's fault.
I mean, that's not like saying nobody
should go to university. That's just
saying most people that are there
shouldn't be there in the first place,
which was already true before AI. Okay.
system enables.
No, it's the system's fault that this
stuff passes. It's the students fault
for taking advantage of it.
Yeah. If you don't enjoy like if you're
like if you don't enjoy the thing and
like you have absolutely no interest in
it and it's just a vehicle to make
money, like stop. You're always going to
be bad at it. Like go do something else.
Like most people I knew at Stanford in
CS should not have been studying CS.
It's also incredibly depressing to
people who actually give a [ __ ] to be
surrounded by people like that. Like
that I will say is not your fault. If
like you're super depressed being in
that system, that's not your fault.
That's the system's fault.
But if your response is like, "Oh, well,
these people don't care, so I'm not
going to care either." That's your
fault.
Cheating is not the system's fault.
That's your fault.
Being super depressed because a bunch of
the people around you got their way but
there by cheating. That's not your
fault.
I worked well over a hundred hours per
week um through all of my formative
years.
I did not cheat on any of my stuff.
I was super overworked and depressed
because it's impossible not to be when
doing that much stuff. And uh you know
it would definitely have helped if
others were not just skating by doing
that. But
coding functional languages on papers
and exams. Don't take a functional
programming class.
That easy
on we actually we're trying to do actual
stuff here. Let me not get sidetracked
too much. Um,
I'm trying to figure out why this
doesn't work with a larger buffer.
We definitely don't want to prioritize
by advantage. That's too much.
I know. I didn't feel like undergrad was
competitive at all.
It was mostly just like trying to
minimize the amount of time that was
wasted by [ __ ] like [ __ ] classes
if I could do research and do like
actual stuff that mattered.
I want to do a program in order to make
money.
CS Gener change the lies. Uh it
do you have you ever had to work with
the codebase of somebody who just
clearly does not give a [ __ ] and is
treating it like you know a whatever 9
to5?
These people make a lot of money by
doing millions and millions of dollars
in damage to their companies.
Like literally one bad programmer on an
important project can easily do tens of
millions of dollars of damage by like
making the entire team just in unable to
do anything. I've seen it happen many
times.
It's like you don't see it because it's
writing code, but like you wouldn't want
a lazy bridge engineer, would you? No.
a cod's loadbearing on all of modern
life.
Like CS in particular is a discipline
where it is very very common to find
people in their first couple of years
that are better than people who have
been doing it for 20 years.
I guess another way of looking at it is
not just pure laziness. Like
there are many jobs that you can do that
are hard but you can do them while just
completely mentally checked out. You
cannot you cannot program this way.
Like even what I'm doing here, like this
feels [ __ ] terrible because of the
lack of responsiveness
um and the long feedback cycles between
what I'm doing. Like I absolutely hate
having to do this type of work. I'm
going to be way happier once I get back
to like getting into the actual puffer
internals and figuring out how to
efficiently integrate whatever solution
we come up with.
Cuz this is basically me just thinking
like, uh, all right, how do I fix this
thing with the algorithm? How do I fix
this other thing with the algorithm? and
then having to wait 10 minutes to see if
I'm right.
Back to 13 score.
14 score.
Is this going to work? Is this going to
work better than before?
Got my 15 solve. Yeah. So, we're just
waiting. Okay, there's the 15 solve.
Come on, latch.
Latch. Come on.
Okay, it'll be on par, I think.
A, that would be so weird, though.
It'll just take it a second. Yeah, there
we go. It latches. Cool. 1.2 bill.
Okay. So, that's on par. We're good.
Yeah.
Okay. So, this is good.
Okay. So, top K best solve segments is
good.
Dynamic environment. What do you mean
dynamic environment?
Okay. So, the admission this is still
domain hacked.
Using solved segments is domain hack.
Torch versus Jax.
Uh, Torch is a good design implemented
terribly.
Jax is a terrible design implemented
like decently.
Oh, it latches like that. Why is it so
spiky?
Yeah. So, Finn, this is kind of the
theory with um
this is sort of the theory with Puffer 5
is that we should be able to get
efficient credit assignment from a
single lucky reward.
And it seems like if you have good state
data, this is mostly true.
It's just a a matter of how do we
automatically get good state data into
the buffer
market order book for market. Uh yes, we
do that type of stuff professionally.
Our main professional service at Puffer
is we build high performance simulations
for a variety of domains including
finance and commerce.
Part of environments is a variable that
changes
dynamics of the N
Is the variable like can you observe the
variable? Is there any way to see what
instance of the problem you're in?
So it is a little bit delayed Finn.
However, um a lot of that I found is
just due to the mini batch size. So,
like it's not actually getting that many
gradient updates in this many steps.
There are a few cases where it seems
like it's a little too delayed.
Um, however, I I think it does somewhat
make sense because you have to realize
it's not getting an expert trajectory.
It's getting a really really crappy
trajectory that solves the level. And
this is not like the time to do
imitation learning. This is essentially
the time that it has to take through
random resets to like get the last few
stage and then get the middle of it and
then get the start of it and get it all
the way through.
So there is still quite a lot that has
to be done. So it's not guaranteed that
it will latch instantly from um
you know instantly in very few steps but
you should not have to go get the reward
again at least you know you should be
able to do it just from the curriculum
buffer
variable is visible. Well, I need to
know more about the problem then cuz in
theory that seems like that could be
totally fine and we do that type of
stuff all the time.
I don't know. I really don't watch very
many like technical podcast to be honest
with you.
1210. I'm going to give myself a little
bit of time before my meetings. One,
Oh, we literally have an energy trading
sim, though it's a very basic like
that's one very basic part of a much
larger sim. Um, it's open that's open
source as well. That's for um archive
repos on the puffer on the puffer github
initiing behavior on maximum usage.
Unless you're setting something up
something up weirdly. That type of
problem seems like it should just work
fine.
If I get this algorithm, this is going
to be an awesome blog post. It's
literally, we'll just title it, one
reward is all you need.
Man, I was so annoyed though that I
didn't just finish this in the first
week. I thought I was literally just
going to have this done in a week. Um, I
think probably if I tried the original
algorithm versus Puffer 3, I would have
been done in a week. But Puffer 4 is
such a strong baseline that you actually
need to be doing some pretty smart
things to do better.
One cookie is all you need.
One Comcast day is equal to an eighth of
a real day.
There.
Yeah, you do. Like that is a risk, Finn.
But the thing is that's supposed to only
be a risk of the Oracle policy or the
Oracle method. Uh we have stuff built
into this in the general method that
should work for that. But because we're
still ablating versus Oracle, we're just
ignoring the problem for now.
We'll see if this works.
I think the really big one is this
mastery gate thing, which is essentially
letting not letting it get too far ahead
of where it's currently solved.
Yeah. This idea just I think in some
sense this idea of this has to work. It
might just be that the um the problem
has more subtleties than you initially
would uh tend to appreciate.
Okay. So, whatever we're using right now
for the metric to um admit segments
is not good.
We'll try this and if not we'll just go
start ablating different methods metrics
is fine.
I have not checked this in a while.
Anything? Nope.
Just the stream notifications.
That's funny.
AI is very profitable if you're Nvidia.
Does the policy Oh, yeah. I already
answered that.
All right, cool. So, we'll see
without the mastery gate.
Okay. So, essentially the concern here,
right, is that it starts to get segments
or advantage segments that are too far
ahead.
But I think what could happen here,
right, is like one of the segments that
takes a long time to latch
It's very possible that this thing
fails. If it doesn't fail, that's one
very, very big chunk of domain knowledge
ablated out though.
See, we're already on 10 here.
Okay, that latch is 10.
Long range spatial.
Uh, you do not want to be putting 1024x
1024 into a neural net. That's a million
obs. So,
a long memory and some partially
observable thingy. Some partially
observable setup.
We're going to commit this one if this
is 15 here. This is a new uh best.
That's awesome.
Come on. Don't fail on 15.
Oh, perfect. Holy crap.
That's 750 mil step solved.
do authentication real quick.
That's a win.
That's a nice win for the morning.
So, we're basically down to just um a
few little bits of domain knowledge to a
blade out. And it's probably going to
come down to just the um like the
criterion that we use to put stuff into
the buffers.
That's pretty awesome.
No, I didn't remove the walls.
What if you need something like a maze
search where you need that long range?
We have the best maze policy out there.
Like for I'm pretty sure we have the
best mazes for just your standard onpaul
RL
by an order of magnitude.
We just have a very good memory. Like
the network just has good memory in it.
Memory plus curriculum is all you
needed.
Oh, have you seen? So, our policies are
way better than this now. But
do we have this on the website? I think
I did put this on the website.
Literally.
All right, just go to ocean and watch
our maze solving policy for a little
bit.
Come on, load.
There. That's our maze solving policy.
It can only see a little box around
itself.
This thing doesn't use search. Doesn't
use any heristics.
This is just like your standard onpl
with a standard benchmark. Now you see
it's not perfect.
Um it explores like very wide ranges of
stuff, but here it needs to know to make
this turn to proceed. This is a very
hard maze if you look at it like
to go around this way.
See like it went down. This is an entire
trap here.
But it's got this very good coherence to
it, right?
Where it's like it's not just like
jittering in one little tiny portion of
the maze.
And our current maze models, I believe,
are even better than this.
So, it's explored like twothirds of this
maze at this point.
You do eventually get limited by the
memory. Like it doesn't know that it's
like this is 100 steps or whatever.
Here, let's see this one.
That's pretty good.
It's very close.
Oops.
I wonder if I have it set up
deterministic
Wonder if I take over.
I bet you if I nudge it a little bit.
No, I can't.
Yeah, if I nudge it a little bit,
it then it figures it out. It didn't
know that last turn for some reason.
Maze search. These don't use search
though. This is literally just on polarl
without even a special model.
Well, presumably this update will help
with mazes a lot as well. We will see.
Okay, build this.
I'd be pretty surprised if this works,
but
this would save us a lot of time.
Hopefully, it at least has the decency
to fail quickly if it is going to.
I guess cuz it's not allowed to have it
has to wait for a lucky solve each time.
Something's messed up with the the
metrics though.
most can be solved with just a ton of
interactions. No, you know, we have
algorithmic
upgrades as well.
Like the maze that maze policy is better
than our maze policy in puffer 3 because
of the new architecture and such.
Like puffer is not even particularly
sample inefficient.
um less common jazz technically you
could
but most of the time you need encoders.
I mean you could write custom decoders
we just haven't needed them.
The only thing slightly obnoxious about
that is that um
we assume that the last element
of your action output is for the value
function. We have a fused value function
head. the way we do it at the moment.
be done in about 10 minutes because I
have to work on uh client stuff.
We did get um one very very good thing
though, right? We got rid of there. We
had this mastery mechanic which was um
this pretty heavy assumption that you
don't get like the next level's data in
your buffer until you fully solve the
previous one. We got rid of that and it
actually does better without it. So
that's basically onethird of the domain
assumptions we're making gone.
you do not understand how unbelievably
cursed it has been to get this thing to
[ __ ] work.
All right. It's like the idea is solid,
but the specific implementation of state
sets is going to matter a lot. Um, it
stuff does not just fall over the second
you do anything remotely state set
based.
pretty much just the way the exact
metric that you base how you put data
into the state buffer on as well as the
exact metric you use for ejecting data
from that buffer matters a lot.
broke something even just [ __ ] with
logs.
All right. Well, I will continue this
after um my client work session.
What's this? convert. I'll check this
real quick.
Oh, very fun. You got a line follower,
huh?
That's fun.
Nice man
with puffer. Cool.
Okay. Um, thank you very much folks for
tuning in. I might be back in the
afternoon. We will see how uh how the
work session for a client goes.
If you're new around here and you have
not starred Puffer on GitHub, please
take a moment to do that. All our
stuff's at puffer.ai
and uh it actually helps out a huge
amount. Like you'd be surprised how much
just starring the repo helps us.
You can follow me on X for more content.
You can join Discord if you want to get
involved with dev.
More research streams coming soon.
Hopefully we'll have the algorithm
finalized in the next few days.
Last question here from uh
lunch.
I didn't I wasn't
summer class to get into their grad
program.
Uh, I don't know if that helps you get
into their grad program at all, frankly.
I guess maybe with maybe a strong letter
of wreck could help, I suppose.
Uh, it really depends on circumstances.
I will say that I did well, if you're
currently a high school student, I did
do one of Stanford's summer programs. It
was the one that just lets you take
classes. And I will say that was
probably the most fun I've ever had in
any summer, as well as where I learned
like a huge amount of stuff. So, if you
have the ability to do that, uh it's the
actual it used to be called summer
college. It's the one where you just
actually take real classes from the
university alongside whoever else is
there like undergrads. It's not one of
the bullshitty programs where they come
up with some dumb curriculum for high
school students.
um the quality of the people I met in
that program like I would say that 80%
of the people in that program were
smarter than the average actual Stamford
like first year undergrad and they were
already smart like better by their
sophomore year of high school. So I had
a ton of fun with that. Um and it
definitely helped me as well. I didn't
get a wreck letter from that, I don't
think.
But I did learn a bunch of stuff that
let me do a bunch of cool research work
thereafter.